the singular reason that I deal with
negative comments so easily it's because
I have empathy for them yeah I feel bad
for them
you got your perspective be happy don't
you want to be happy hey guys
here the man you saw Gary need to talk
about all things mental health okay I
think you don't mental health all wrong
as a society we named it something
negative mental health even met health
awareness its awareness this big scary
beast Shore health short on time flip it
on its head and make mental health this
thing that we all trying to achieve
rather than trying to avoid yeah I think
that's right I think the first way we
can do that is to change it to mental
happiness instead of mental health or
put to your point position it a little
bit lighter yeah cuz it feels heavier
[ __ ] there's some things that with me
when I met you the first of which was
you mentioned something about wanted to
meditate right but that you were bit
scared to do it because you were it was
something yeah I mean I think it was a
litany oh yeah much like a lot of things
I do a little bit of a bit as
tongue-in-cheek
but I I I think it's important to
preserve things that are working yeah
and I think sometimes people you know
you look at athletes that overwork
something that's working and then they
get injured right and so you know the
tongue-in-cheek statement of like I'm
scared to do meditation because I might
[ __ ] up something is more of an ode to
like jeez I'm so grateful so grateful
for my mental you know happiness that
I'm not there's nope let me say it on
the record I do not believe that if I
started to meditate that it would unlock
some door that opened up a new framework
that made me not as happy at the same
token I'll be very frank I'd rather have
those 25 minutes to do something else
whether it's exercise whether it's to
spend time with somebody whether it's to
work on my business because I'm because
at least for now it's going the way I
feel and I also do believe what I'm
about to say I feel like I'm meditating
times I'm very capable of deploying
macro perspective at all time like
literally as we sit here now there's
something running in my brain that says
god it's so good that everybody you care
about is healthy right that's amazing
that's a credible
yeah and that's that's the thing that we
guess everyone should try to take is
that ability to be present at all times
in what they're doing and be able to do
and that's that kind of answer the other
thing that I wanted to ask you about
clouds and dirt as a philosophy it's
phenomenal and it kind of resonates
deeply with a lot of things that I
believe which is that you know I always
always describe that it's taken on a
super position like which is when kind
of tiny little atoms can take on two
different states that don't appear to be
related in any way actually
contradictory at the same time and
that's kind of what you are getting out
with the planet they're right in as much
as you've got to be both here and up
here at the same time and not so it's
kind of being able to say in the same in
this thing soon taneous ly rather in the
middle right massive global massive you
know audacious perspective yeah and deep
practical capabilities yeah you know
double peas right if you can have
perspective proper macro perspective and
you can have micro you know practitioner
ship you will be happy and win yeah I
really believe that yeah having the
humility and the audacity back to your
contradiction but yeah I mean that's how
I got to clouds and dirt you know cuz
I've always been fascinated by that
about me which is the things I'm willing
to do right now that are below my pay
grade
this podcast this is super scrutinized
by the people around me it's like why
are you doing this we don't have 15
minutes for very important [ __ ] you're
letting money opportunity VIPs why are
you doing this I don't know like
intuitively when we were talking I
thought it was a good idea and I want to
I think you know in my massive person
you know perspective giving back I look
you're going to leverage me being on the
show for sure and that makes me feel
good that's me giving back this is a
bigger thing giving you these 15 minutes
than me giving you $15,000 for your app
for me it's easier to write the check so
so for me humility and like perspective
like I don't think I don't know how many
very busy people are running around
knowing that they need to put change
into the bucket of giving back in their
time not their money always always on to
what you're feeling yeah yeah that goes
back to why would I need to stop my
state to do that when that's the only
thing I'm doing how did you get there
I have no goddamn idea really so you
don't you don't know who's like your
childhood your parents you look of
course right DNA circumstance you know
could nature nurture but then then that
doesn't allow me to say well then go do
this what I can do is I can the thing I
like to do is reinforce through my words
because communication is the most
powerful tool of like what is happening
here like yesterday I'm like save your
money that's a practical tangible advice
and then to posts earlier that a lot of
people see is in 35 years your grandkids
will read everything you've posted have
the perspective I don't want to sell
anybody a course I don't want to
pontificate that I do these 13 steps
people and you'll be like me I'm just
speaking the truth and probably no
different than what maybe how I got
there was hearing truths I'm very good
at eating my own dog food so like you
know even your question maybe just got
me into a place listening to my mom's
macro perspective being forced to be a
practitioner because I was bad at school
so if you're gonna make money go make
money survive in society work hard work
matters I'm very passionate about
sharing my points of view for free in
perpetuity and I have a communication
style that clearly resonates
and so then all of a sudden once I
figured out that that was true then it
became a sense of a responsibility I'm
very aware that for an enormous amount
of 21 year old guys in the world I'm
gonna be the guy that puts them on to
kindness and gratitude and empathy
nobody else can do it I believe that I
think the way that you framed kindness
and empathy in a way that is practical
as well as it again even-even anything
cool right yeah like if you're gonna
break through an 18 year old guy you're
not gonna get him absolute altruism
you're not gonna get them right you're
right right and so I don't have ideology
I just have ambition there's no way I
want to go about doing it I just want it
to happen I want everybody to be happier
kinder more grateful more empathetic a
lot of good will happen there's so much
abundance yeah there's a much food gets
thrown out in New York City every night
we have abundance in the macro it there
and so I think that there's an abundance
of love but it's not being deployed and
I want to think about that nice so when
things don't go your way how do you ever
go to a place bad place so you've been
anxious you ever been down to the point
where things feel a little on control no
no and honestly I think it will I think
will happen when well cuz I think
somebody's that I love is gonna die thus
I'll feel some of that you know I think
most people feel out of control in
business and relationships I don't care
about money and I never want to do the
wrong thing for another person which
gives me all the leverage to not be in
that place you know people get anxious
because somebody else has more leverage
with them in their relationship and they
need them but they can't control them
and that's when that person goes awry in
a different direction they feel anxious
nobody has a relationship with me where
they have the leverage emotionally okay
so that makes me not have that issue and
then very frank man and let just one sit
for [ __ ] all I just don't care about
the money yeah like I'm fine making 47
thousand a year and reading all the
comments on Instagram and LinkedIn that
I was
lost at all interested interested that I
gave a hell of a lot more than I took I
want to be I want to be the greatest
entrepreneur of all time because
entrepreneurship is what I do and I
think the way to do that is to a build
big businesses and exits and companies
and put the points on the board right
but Who I am right I mean like like I
want to inspire the most entrepreneurs
to be happy not just successful okay
like there's so many people are gonna be
unhappy making a million a year that
would have been thrilled making six
thirty that is the number one
conversation that matters to make
awareness that's crack and that's
exactly what this is all about is that
you know when you know yourself then the
stuff could happen to any of us you know
people can die things can happen we
could lose not anything but when you
know what it is that moves you well you
know what it is that makes you how you
think then that stuff can't affect you
in the way that it can when it just
seems random and when you use that
self-awareness as a leverage point to
eliminate the judgment of others
absolutely people are struggling because
of judgment it come it's an outside
source that creates a inside voice that
makes you believe it people judge in
real life yeah because those because
they're insecure so that's exactly one
course so like but it starts it starts
with parents yeah I mean the amount of
parents let's talk about immigrant
cultures right right yeah parents put
pressure because they care about what
other parents think about their kids the
brown culture the Asian culture the
Eastern European culture like it's it's
the Asian culture you know just it's
very obvious yeah in the moment that we
all grew up being a doctor and a lawyer
an engineer is on a pedestal that's the
current thing that's on a pedestal yeah
thus you need to be one correct why
because it's important for the
generation above you and that's how they
judged each other absolutely
the reason I'm happiest cuz my mom
didn't give a [ __ ] about other people's
if my mom was cliche like every other
Eastern European Jewish mom that she
came over to this country with from
Russia my would be a miserable NYU
doctor - yeah so to me I can't Bank on
the world having a mom like me so now
I've decided to be their mom and I'm not
even that yeah and that's really real
for me bro like I I have a level of
guilt and gratitude and it's a mix that
is manifested in me making this content
I want to be that guy for them yeah cuz
I was given it that's amazing and then
so get going back to that then so what
that creates I guess is when I have my
own insecurities came over then what I
do is well yeah so what I try and do
then is I try to eject them on a horse
misery loves company that's a very wheel
can I tell you something the singular
reason that I deal with negative
comments so easily it's cuz I have
empathy for them yeah I feel bad for
them absolutely the thought that I would
ever spend the time to go on somebody
else's account and [ __ ] on them with my
three minutes oh wait
I'm gonna watch your video for a minute
and then think for a minute and then
write for a minute that you're a loser
and that was stupid
you must be broke yeah emotionally so so
yeah I'm trying to polish things I was
at Facebook through the day with mental
health event and I was trying to tell
all these guys that when communities
there why don't we rehabilitation 12 cuz
like I don't yeah cuz that's that's how
I want to engage it right yeah but but
but you know what I think we need to be
careful and not be altruistic why don't
we understand absolutely right yes so
you know what I mean absolutely because
when somebody here is you're gonna
rebuilt it maybe it's like it [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you you know you got me it's why we
listen you're very smart you're right
about mental health positioning matters
this is why this is why I am Who I am
words matter right so for me and not not
that I'm jumping on it because I say
things like but if we can his wife why
do you think I call my wine empathy have
empathy come from that framework
that's where it's at as soon as I mean
I'm leading a perfectly then everything
changes the game changes everything
internally it all changes because then
you suddenly realize you know where does
he come from it comes from a fear of the
unknown or a projection of my own 100%
as soon as I understand that then then
hate to me feels very different 100%
it's such a weakness hate is such a
weakness when I see hate I am like wow
this person is very weak
yeah and they think if they're strong
but people are confused yeah humility
and empathy and gratitude that strength
absolutely that's exactly it so thank
you it was so much I'm glad we did it
thank you man one less thank you feel it
moved it in there for me what's that
feel it moved it what's up everybody
it's gary vaynerchuk feel it mood it
thank you guys they're walking brother
talk to you soon
you